people here in great amounts have been
living under restrictions for three
months
and they have taken a heavy toll
on people they're struggling businesses
are on the brink of closure to accept
any further restrictions
in these circumstances would be certain
to increase
levels of poverty homelessness
and hardship within our city region
let's be clear who is most affected
by a tier 3 lockdown it is people
working in pubs in bookies
driving taxis people too often forgotten
by those in power but
this city region has never walked on by
and it never will at the start of these
negotiations together with the leaders
of our councils we made a commitment to
all of those people that we would look
out for them
and stand up for what is right
it cannot be right it cannot be right
to close people's place of work to shut
somebody's business without giving them
proper support
so that they can look after themselves
their families
through a very challenging winter
that lies ahead of us
so we've been clear throughout we could
only accept further restrictions with
full financial support
we put forward a costed package of
measures
a detailed package of measures but in
particular to support
people on the lowest incomes and people
who are self-employed
15 million pounds a month was what we
costed was needed to support people
across
the 10 boroughs that make up greater
manchester these would be people
who would need support to top up the
furlough
to 80 that people can't live on
two-thirds of their wages
people who are self-employed also with
eighty percent of their income so that
they could make
ends meet that was the commitment that
we made
so this would cost 90 million pounds to
the end of the financial
year in negotiations with the government
we were prepared to reduce our request
to 75 million
and we even were prepared to go even
lower
65 million as the bare minimum to
prevent
a winter of real hardship here that is
what we
believe we needed to prevent poverty to
prevent
hardship to prevent homelessness
those were the figures that we had not
what we wanted
what we needed to present prevent all of
those things
happening but the government refused
to accept this and at two o'clock today
they walked away from negotiations
in summary at no point today were we
offered enough
to protect the poorest people in our
communities
through the punishing reality of the
winter to come
even now i am still willing to do a deal
but it cannot be on the terms that the
government offered today because on
those terms i could not meet the
commitments i made
to people on the lowest incomes to
people who are self-employed to the
freelancers in this city
who need our support i could not do it
on those terms and i don't think it is
right
to ask people to go into a lockdown to
accept further changes with
within their lives without supporting
them through
all of that and what it entails it can't
be right to do that how can we carry the
public with us
through this pandemic if we are forcing
them
to lose
their income their place of work
without supporting them through that
how is that going to keep people with
what's being done here to fight this
virus
so finally i don't believe we can
proceed
as a country on this basis through
the pandemic by grinding communities
down
through punishing financial negotiations
we are asking a lot of the public at
this difficult time
and we need to carry them with us not
crush
their spirit we need national unity
and that is why i now look to parliament
to intervene and make a judgment on a
fair
financial framework for tier three
lockdowns because make no mistake this
was not just about greater manchester
all parts of the country may find
themselves in a tier three lockdown at
some point this winter
and what we need to be able to say to
people living in those areas
is that they have a guarantee that they
can plan for should they need it
80 percent of their wages or their
income that is the least that we owe to
those people
the money that businesses will be able
to rely on to survive
we should be setting out that fair
financial
framework i want to finish by speaking
directly
to the people of greater manchester
because i know they felt
a lot of uncertainty over the last week
as these negotiations have played out we
know this is going to be
a difficult time for you but together
with the leaders behind me and all of
the leaders of greater manchester
we took this stand for you we will carry
on
fighting for you we will carry on
putting your health
first but health is more than the virus
we will
support people's health in the broadest
possible sense
so tough days lie ahead please
everybody observe the law at
all times and follow the public health
advice above all else please
look out for each other as i know you
will thank you very much